hey there i'm rose hey guys it's your
girl denali
hello world it's tamisha iman hi
everybody it's top moral hall the mackie
doll
hey everybody it's me tina berner your
favorite linebacker in a dress
oh my goodness hello it's utica queen
the art fart from small farm town
hello hi i'm olivia lux hi
i'm candy muse hi baby i am miss joey j
hi i'm larry hello i'm simone hi i'm
gotnick and i'm elliott with twotees
and we are the cast of rupaul's drag
race season 13
playing who's who's with buzzfeed honey
who's most likely to read anyone to fill
candy
i fell for that one uh you said yourself
yes
you were my number two my number one was
candy my number two was tamisha
can read i said mick i said got nick
nick yeah
but like in the i mean in like the best
way possible like they will tell you if
you look busted
run down they will get to the point yeah
i guess yeah mixed nasty about it i just
try to be
constructive got me maybe candy
and you're ready michelle absolutely
doll have you watched the show before
[Laughter]
good old tina burner tina has been doing
drag for so long so she has
a lot of opinions but she's really
educated
i said timisha you know she is a patrick
girl she's been in drag for a very long
time
and those pageant girls don't play
around i definitely said candy muse
not necessarily because she's like
coming for someone but she'll just
whatever thought that
popped in her mind she'll vocalize it
and she'll say it who's most likely to
come back as one of the
secret lip sync assassins in a new
all-star season
denali i think denali
is such a fierce competitor she's a
great performer
and i mean i've seen her instagram she
like does ice skating
so i can only imagine what she does on
the dance floor i definitely said denali
as well
like talk buck twirl splits kick like
she will throw it all at you and has no
shame doing it it's
sickening to watch so fingers crossed
i'd love to see it
la la la la la la house
it's just me on that stage and whoever
i'm going against you better watch out
for stuff
denali denali i said la la re
oh that's a good one too yes
yes
i'm very confident in my lip-sync
assassin abilities let's just say
that but i also will say lala is
definitely in my mind in the running
who's most likely
to become a viral meme during the season
candy i think in my opinion is gonna go
down in history like
icons of reality television absolutely
candy shop
i don't know why wait what did you say i
said tamisha
no i don't know why i forgot about candy
yeah can i change my answer can't yes
candy candy
candy candy muse here's the thing
i'm a very i don't know expression of
the word but my face gives very much
expressions and i guess that's something
that things
are very funny i don't really realize
that but you know what
i love being a viral queen who's most
likely to have the
messiest workstation at any given time
i did my makeup right next to gotmick
and first station literally just spanned
the entire
the entirety of everything that station
exploded all over the world
it was a mess i said myself because like
when i'm doing my makeup like my adv
kicks in right away and i'll have like
one nail on one table a nail on the
other table
a glue on a third table the handlers
were always like running back to go get
things i like
would walk on the runway and then
realize i forgot a part of a costume
like
it was the whole thing tina candy
i mean i should change it to candy
actually candy's a slob
i did throw my clothes somewhere but it
was organized chaos as we like to call
it god
[Laughter]
kimura and gottmick have the cleanest
faces
i think of our season but the absolute
messiest workstation
like they fully had to like readjust how
the cameras filmed because all yo
was pouring into the entranceway of the
work room
and i had like lube spilled all over the
floor yeah
girl the look she was wet honey they
should have put me in the corner
who's most likely to borrow a piece of
clothing in the work room
all of y'all right all of us
is definitely that that's like backstage
at the show like
where'd you get that yeah candy wore
more of my shoes than i did like
absolutely candy candy oh
lord every time candy borrowed something
like candy has this really cool thing of
making it her own
definitely me because going into the
competition i prepared myself to the
ability that i could
you know there are 12 other queens here
one got an extra pair of gloves
denali yeah i said you tina watch
me a personal experience i just said
denali just because we're the same
shoe size so we can easily share shoes
at any point i borrowed rosa's shoes as
well yeah
i'm the hamburglar who's most likely to
get ready the fastest
looking flaw free utica utica
and our makeup is intricate i'm still on
like moisturizer how are you already
done
denali then i was going to deny a denali
when you're in that situation
they're all yelling at you like get
ready take your pictures olivia
olivia's good but i don't know if i
would say she's the fastest
got make like literally is like and her
like face is done
simone i said jelly joey would be the
first
one first of all jordan would talk the
most and still
be the first one done i mean true who's
most likely to show up late to a gig
oh actually no actually
i stay with candy because i feel like
kamora
if her gig was at eight pm she would
start painting at eight a.m
and still be there on time but candy
would put it off maybe drink some wine i
feel like there's been moments where
i've been facetiming candy
and it's fully 30 minutes before the gig
and she's in full boy just chilling
and i'm like candy don't you have a show
to go to we don't even need to vote
there's no three two one we would all be
in agreeance it is come on
i got ready at like 5 a.m for this okay
like i need my time i can
beauty cannot be rushed come on come on
you
the moment she sits down to pick up a
makeup brush she literally goes in slow
motion
who's most likely to flirt with a pit
crew member
finale
oh my god of course you are of course a
contender
for this question i'm a thirsty gal okay
everyone
everyone i was gonna say myself but just
because i i want
the pit crew member but everybody wants
to pick up everyone
your frustration builds up in the world
oh my god
like is that what they call it these
days frustration
olivia rose i said simone i said utica
who's most likely to have their own drag
race spin-off series
candy for the love of games for the love
of candy for the love of candy
peanut burner maybe mick with makeup
i saw myself i've always wanted a dating
show
a shout out lovely candy muse very like
flavor of love out of new york
candy candy absolutely personality of
all seasons ever literally like the most
giant personality i've ever come across
in my
whole life candy candy i would say
myself just because i want my own
but i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna say
candy because kenny is the kind of
person you know who's just gonna force
herself on any producer
she's a whole production in herself
she's like a walking cartoon character
everything she says is so funny how you
see her and then meet the queens and how
she is in person like that that is candy
who's most likely
to last respond in the group chat lala i
said to me
is that what you said wow
[Laughter]
only because tamisha has a samsung too
so yeah she's still figuring out how to
get to the group chat on her nokia
[Laughter]
me lala will come in three weeks later
be like y'all but i mean
well a lot of people don't know is
tamisha doesn't have an iphone
so the season 13 has 12 out of the 13
girls have an iphone so we have a group
chat
but so she's not involved in the group
chats
who's most likely to be crying backstage
candy muse
and the muse i think candy is just so
passionate
i said denali because like we would
hands down like leave the stage and then
we're all just sitting there waiting and
i look over and i'm like
work denali that is very true that
always does crawl out too olivia
yeah i should have said kimura you're
right kimura's spirit animal
is like a shaky chihuahua rosary
i didn't see rosie cry once you don't
see her cry on stage i can see rosie
getting emotional back by herself
candy candy she's an emotional angel i
did not know that about it i didn't
either
i did not either it happened like so
quickly in
into things i was like oh reason is
likely to have the biggest wig on at any
given time
olivia it's olivia say la la you said to
me
right yeah to me i will give olivia as
well
here's a little insider tea rose set
up her entire station in the work room
like a freaking walk-in closet basically
90
of it was massive wigs rose really
topped tina
rosa they topped tina you will never
catch me topping tina that is not
something i'm trying to do
to me me i said olivia
i said me you do have really big wigs
who is most likely to have a successful
music career what am i doing
rosie girl rose in the group chat like
download my new album
[Laughter]
by the way i'm so excited for her
thank you dolls i appreciate that who's
most likely to have the longest line at
the next
drag con god wins
you said got mixed to me yes they got me
gummick is
popular with the children and we got
mick is an icon and deserves all of the
love and adoration i say candy as well i
think it's just because she's loud and
memeable
candy i said my two are making candy
yeah making candy on it obviously
got me do we all say got mick yeah you
know we keep saying season 13 is
definitely the renaissance of drag
i'm very very happy that rupaul's drag
race has the first trans man on the show
and i think that's going to be a really
great revolutionary thing so
i know i'm going to be standing in line
i'm not going to be sitting in line
not only does that make building brand
new bridges for drag race to cross
it's gonna inspire so many children that
feel lost in the world and don't really
know much about
how they feel in their own body so got
me for sure me
andy rupaul okay there we go
i'm really excited for our season
personally because i feel like we're all
so different
and yes different drags that like our
fans will be very specific
that's right and i feel like people are
going to be so hungry for
drag they're going to be so hungry for
the interaction in the drag race because
they've gone so long without
that thank you so much buzzfeed we had
so
much fun make sure to tune in season 13
of rupaul's drag race only on vh1
you